>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Carlos Olave: Okay good
evening, my name is Carlos Olave.
I am the head of the
Hispanic reading room.
And on behalf of the Chief
of the Hispanic Division,
Dr. Georgette Dorn, who was
not able to be present today,
I'd like to welcome you to Mr.
Joan Amoros book presentation
about Outstanding Catalan
Contributions.
Founded in 1939 the Hispanic
Division of the Library
of Congress was the
first international
and inner cities reading room
established by this institution.
In the same year the Hispanic
reading room was inaugurated
to service the libraries growing
[inaudible] of Hispanic collections.
The reading room is the center for
Hispanic studies and offers services
in English, Spanish and Portuguese.
About 250 researchers visit
the reading room each month
to view this Hispanic
materials of all kinds.
Although its primary emphasis
has always been the acquisition
of current materials and
government documents,
the Hispanic division has also
acquired a rich collection
of rare items.
The division has been instrumental
in acquiring significant gifts
of manuscripts, music scores,
posters, photographs and films.
It has developed special
use of materials
such as collecting folk
music from San Antonio,
Texas and pioneering the
recording of Hispanic writers
through it's archives of
Hispanic literature on tape.
Which is currently and
gradually being digitized
for wider public access.
The Library of Congress houses
13.5 million items related
to the Luso-Hispanic world.
Of these 13.5 million items 3.2
million are books and serials.
The staff of the Hispanic reading
room oversees these materials,
they assist researchers in
retrieving items such as maps,
recordings, manuscripts, prints,
photographs references
books and artifacts.
The Library of Congress has amassed
the world's finest collection
on the history and culture
of Iberia, Latin America
and the Caribbean and that
of the Hispanic population
in the United States.
Many of the rare items
were received as gifts
such as the rare books
donated by Lessing J. Rosenwald
and manuscripts given
by Hans P. Kraus.
Gifts and bequests have
enable the Hispanic Division
to purchase materials in
various formats in addition
to books and periodicals.
And now I would like to
introduce you to Maria Molina,
the culture attache of the
Spanish embassy, Maria.
[ Applause ]
>> Maria Molina Alvarez
de Toledo: Thank you,
so I'm the cultural counsellor,
I'm head of the cultural office.
We have a cultural center
in 16th Street by the way
and I would be happy
to host you there.
We are in charge of the cultural
promotion of Spanish culture
and all kinds of exchanges,
different culture and arts.
And to fulfill that mission we have
created a program called Spain Arts
and Culture.
Who aims to bring quality shows,
quality events and all kinds
of authors, artists and performers.
From very renown to less
renowned emerging young artists.
Well, I'd like to first thank the
Hispanic division for inviting me
and for organizing this event,
for being such a valuable partner,
for us, for other Spanish speaking
countries and also Portuguese
because you are really important
to us for your collection
and for all you do, thank you.
I wish to congratulate
the author and his team,
which I think they
are heroes as well
for producing that wonderful work.
I'm eager to read it, to
share it with the embassy
and we're certainly proud of you.
And of course Catalonia's
contribution to the arts
of culture of Spain and worldwide.
The imprint they have left all
over the world, not only Catalonia
but I understand other
Catalan speaking regions
which are referred to
in the book, I guess.
So we're proud of being diverse in
Spain, of being rich and varied,
having different identities and
particularly we're very proud
of Catalonia's contribution.
Which has always been very important
because it's been a beacon
of our arts and culture.
Traditionally, historically
and also currently now a days.
For sure it's thrived in many
traditions that you know of customs,
celebrations but not only, it's
always been at the vanguard
of contemporary art of
architectural design.
It's a literary hub, it's
the mecca still in Spain
for the publishing world in Spanish
and for the Spanish speaking world.
And it's still producing very
interesting and innovative ideas
and festivals such --
I'd like to mention some.
That I look at like [inaudible]
or some other festival
but there are many others
with which we like to work
and they're very important
world-wide.
Our embassy's focused on of
course fostering connections
between the U.S. and
Spain and Catalonia.
Of course they have a very
big role to play and we would
like to continue helping
that, enhancing that.
So thank you very much and thank you
for inviting me to
talk as well, enjoy.
[ Applause ]
>> Carlos Olave: And now we have
Dr. Juan Perez, who will speak
about the Hispanic collections, he
is our Spanish Reference specialist.
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Perez: The Library of
Congress possesses a rich collection
of items from Spain including books,
maps, newspapers, manuscripts,
photographs and other items.
Examples, include the first
edition of the Quixote 1605,
the book of Privileges of
Christopher Columbus 1502,
the first Hispanic language
dictionary from 1611.
We may very well have
the best collection
about the Spanish Civil
War outside of Spain
and the includes 123
original posters.
Some of them actually is
some were by the government
and others by the rebel side.
Many of those posters were
printed by the general [inaudible].
From that period of the Civil
War I always like to mention
that we have a very special book or
very special poem by Pablo Neruda
which he dedicated to Spain,
it's called Espana en el Corazon.
And it was published in Girona
in 1938 by the [inaudible]
and the peculiarity
of the poem not only
because it's such a beautiful poem.
But also what makes it peculiar
is the fact that the material
that was used to produce the paper
came from the uniforms or shirts
of republican soldiers who
had died around the area
in Girona and other places.
There are only two or three copies
now available and we have one
of those copies of course
is under lock and key.
That region is [inaudible] of the
[inaudible] holdings is reflected
in our variety of the
Catalonia holdings.
For example we have books on
or by [inaudible] Pablo Casals
and they represent maybe
almost 2,000 volumes.
And for Pablo Casals we
also have lots of video
and film of his concerts.
Many of them edited
by the [inaudible] Pablo
Casals from Puerto Rico.
But we also have more contemporary
writers like [inaudible]
and we even have 16th and
17th century editions of works
by Ramon Lu [phonetic] even one from
the 16th century which is attributed
to him but there are now some
doubts as to whether that work
of archemie [phonetic] is truly his.
And those two works come,
they're both in the same volume
and I think they date from 1541
or something, I'm not quite sure.
But also we have more
contemporary writers as an example,
[inaudible] or [inaudible].
The library even has
an Italian translation
of [inaudible] from 1538.
For history just searching
under Catalonian history it's
over 500 volumes, I can
mention [inaudible] from 1678
to the more contemporary
[inaudible] published in 2015.
Early description of early Catalonia
could be for example geographical
and historical account of the
[inaudible] Park of Catalonia
and [inaudible] of Barcelona
published in London in 1705.
Again to the more contemporary
Barcelona [inaudible] published
in 2015 by [inaudible].
We also have items or books
relating to law and we have several
which are really again
quite outstanding
and again also under lock and key.
Like for example, [inaudible]
book published in 1618
and even a 1621 edition by the
15th century Catalan jurist Tomas
Mirez [phonetic].
His most famous work, we
have this 1621 edition.
And just by closing I,
you know, because we have
so many different items
I was mentioning
to our guest just before we came
in that we may have 12 volumes
of the [inaudible] the famous
comic book by Victor Mora
who just passed away
last year in Barcelona.
So the book which is
being presented today
to the library Outstanding Catalan
Contributions will enhance even more
the richness of our
Spanish materials in general
and Catalonian materials
in particular.
So let me introduce you
to the person who is going
to make the donation to the library
and also talk about the book.
Mr. Joan Amoros holds a doctoral
in industrial engineering.
He's the President of
[inaudible] Catalana.
He has been the director
general of programming and supply
of Nissan Motor [inaudible]
as well as President
of Nissan distribution
service in Barcelona.
He is a member of the
Board of Barcelona Port
and the industrial engineers
association of Catalonia.
And he is the President of
Business Management Commission
of [inaudible].
Social steering committee
And many other associations, just
too long to mention everything.
Mr. Amoros is the author of
many books and has participated
in seminars and conferences on
[inaudible], operational research,
logistics and business management.
He has received several awards among
them the [inaudible] the [inaudible]
and the [inaudible] by the city
of [inaudible] among many others.
So without further
ado Mr. Joan Amoros.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Amoros: Okay, first
of all thank you very much
for your kind invitation
we are very, very,
very pleased to offer this book
to the Library of the Congress
of United States for us it is key
to have this book in this finest
and extraordinary library
all over the world.
Then thank you very much to
the direction of the library,
thank you to the representation of
the Spanish Embassy to come here
with us and all of you, thank you.
Well, I have to talk a little
bit about the book, no.
The book is a heavy book, first of
all it's a heavy book it weighs,
I know it in kilos, it weighs 2.6
kilos then it's quite significant 2
times 4 and to send by mail
is a little bit difficult.
Well, this book starts to, the idea
to do this book it start [inaudible]
2003 but I have been engaged
with many other issues
by putting [inaudible].
The book stops and we
start finally in 2008
and we finish the book in 2014.
Basically because we like to
present the book the Catalan version
of the book considering
the city centuries
after for us was a defeat of 1714.
Then we celebrate, Catalan used
to celebrate the defeat
not the [inaudible].
Because we never win nothing
then we used to celebrate defeat.
Well, then in fact a way
[inaudible] present the book just
in December 2014 in the premises
of the Catalan government.
And perhaps before to continue my
presentation you can see is more
video, only last 5 minutes
and perhaps you would have a
more rough idea of the content
of the book and then
I will continue.
I think they said if I push here.
[ Background noise ]
>> The book about outstanding
Catalan contributions is an
initiative of the Occitano
Catalonian Foundation.
Work on the book began in 2009
instigated by the promotional team
which included the late
Joanne Theodore [phonetic].
The book of outstanding Catalan
contributions is another way
of interpreting the
history of a people
with the contributions it has made.
Which have had an impact
across Europe and the world.
The book is divided
into three parts.
A brief summary of the
history of Catalonia,
descriptions of the
contributions chosen and opinions
of leading figures about
the future of Catalonia.
The book has 744 pages and
almost 1,000 illustrations.
It is published by editorial
[inaudible] in four languages,
Catalan, English, Spanish
and French.
The authors are members of
the promotion team it opens
with a transcript of the speech by
Pablo Casals, the United Nations
on the 24th of October 1971.
>> I am a Catalan, today
a province of Spain.
But what has been Catalonia,
Catalonia has been the
greatest nation in the world.
I tell you, I will tell you why,
Catalonia has had the first
[inaudible] much before England.
Catalonia since the beginning
of the United Nations.
>> The purpose of the
book is two-fold,
to show that Catalonia's
ability to contribute
in all areas makes it
important to European nation.
And to increase self-esteem and
spread the word around the world
that the Catalan people
are an open people.
Capable of projecting
themselves through innovation
and action of universal reach.
The book is being produced
through crowd funding
in which anyone can participate.
Acquiring copies, corresponding
to their contribution.
[ Music ]
The people's ability to contribute
to humanity is inextricably linked
to the [inaudible] of its history.
History is the thread which
follows the trajectory of the people
and guides it toward the future.
The contributions of previous
generations underpin those
and those to come.
[Foreign language]
[ Applause ]
>> The Catalan nation deserves
to occupy it's rightful place
in Europe and the world.
Now is the time to take a major
step forward for Catalonia.
[ Music ]
>> Joan Amoros: Well, the book
here you have rough explanation
of the book and of course
one main aim of the book is
to get aware the Catalan people
regarding the contributions
that you can make because
unfortunately our history
in many occasions has been
forbidden, then it's very difficult,
not difficult but during the
French [inaudible] persecution
to the Catalan culture, the Catalan
language, etcetera, etcetera.
Many people doesn't know
which Catalan people has made.
So the general problems of humanity.
Then we this was the first idea
and the second idea basically was
to get word all over the
world what we have made.
That has been split out
and has [inaudible]
internationally but everywhere.
This is the topic of the book
and as you have seen you can
make four different impressions,
one in Catalan that
have been presented
in [inaudible] government
at the end of 2014.
And by the end of 2015 we present
in the institute [inaudible] the
other version, the Spanish version,
the French version and
the English version.
And now what we are doing is to
present the book all over Catalonia,
all over Europe and
all over the world.
And this is what we are doing
at the moment and the book
as you have seen there
is three parts one
that basically makes a short
explanation only 23 pages.
Of our history in other
that the reader could know
in which context has been made
the contribution in which area
because we start in the middle ages,
there are contributions
from the 10th century.
Catalonia is a very
old nation in Europe.
And after this first
part of the book
as I said there's only [inaudible]
pages following this start the
explanation contribution
by contribution
from the middle ages till now.
There are now positive
contributions that we have made.
I have to say that the
Occitano Catalonian Foundation,
it's not a foundation.
It is a foundation that
has been created in 1990
and basically our aim is to produce,
we have made [inaudible]
regarding Catalan [inaudible]
and we have made [inaudible]
important congresses in 2000
and first and we have
made several publications
and now we can make
this publication.
This is a nonprofit association.
Then we don't have money with this
foundation and I have to say as well
that all the authors of the book
we have made this [inaudible].
And something else that
I think is important is
that we have made this book
without any [inaudible].
And in the second part of the book
there is a description chronological
order [inaudible] all the
different contributions.
And I have to say that
we have contributions
in all fields of activity.
If you look at the top of the
content by topics you will see
that we have contributions in
[inaudible], in philosophy,
[inaudible] in cuisine
and sometimes [inaudible].
In all fields, you'll see that it's
really contributions in all fields.
And we discover because
when we start
to prepare this book we said well,
we'll talk about 100 contributions,
100 of [inaudible] contributions.
But we start to and we saw that
we are passing 100 contributions.
Well, we'll name the book 150
contributions but still we overpass.
And finally the problem is that
we would like to present the book
in 2014 and then we have to
stop and we stopped at 223
that there's a figure that's
it's a little bit [inaudible]
that we stop here.
But I have to say that in fact
there are about 260 or even more
because in many cases we
made group of contributions
in a single contribution.
For instance [inaudible]
we have joined together
and then are there several
hundred contributions.
Then if you are [inaudible]
we can reach 260 [inaudible]
in New York [inaudible] I will
not pronounce very good in English
because Catalan is [inaudible].
But in [inaudible] why you have
not put [inaudible] he was a hero
in the [inaudible] and hero of the
Civil War in the United States.
Well, we forgot in the second
edition [inaudible] then we have
to say that this book [inaudible]
second edition will be good
but this is what I can say to you.
What is important is to say
that at the end of the book,
we have asked the opinion of many
stakeholders in Catalonia today.
From the President of [inaudible]
that is our emblematic bond
in Catalonia to [inaudible] for us
is also an emblematic [inaudible].
Then we have there the
President of the Union,
sorry the general secretaries
of unions,
Presidents of employee associations,
[inaudible] most important
[inaudible] sales,
etcetera, etcetera, etcetera.
Directors of universities, everybody
we ask what is your opinion
regarding this process
of contribution.
Because you have to take into
account that for instance
in 1930 Catalonia only had 2 million
people, now days we have 7.5.
That is very funny
to know that in fact
if we look how many people is really
with all the ancestors
from Catalonia.
[inaudible] only people came
from other part of Spain,
from in Barcelona, I think that they
are allowed 400 different languages.
We have people from
everywhere in the world.
And what is very interesting to
know is that there is no problem.
The [inaudible] is
fantastic in Catalonia
and we are very proud of this.
Catalonia is a melting pot
like it is in the United States
that we have no problems
fortunately,
that for instance you can
see in the shores of London,
on the shores of Paris, we
don't have those problems.
There is very, very good
understanding between all the people
and I think that these are one of
our strong positions at the moment.
It is very complicated for Catalonia
because as you know somebody would
like to get [inaudible]
some are not.
You know what will happen finally
but in fact perhaps now days
in the newspapers everywhere,
we've seen it Catalonia
this, Catalonia that.
Well, here you can see a
book, not a political book.
And perhaps through this book you
can get aware of what is Catalonia,
at least what Catalonia
has to contribute.
To the general progress of the
different countries particularly
in Europe but also
in the United States.
Here in this folder you can find the
least of the contributions related
with the United States and
there are four pages of --
I have not counted [inaudible]
probably close to 100
of this contributions that have a
relationship with the United States.
From the Romanesque art because
in the course there are zero
in New York, there are a lot
of Catalan Romanesque art here
in this [inaudible] but we
have for instance [inaudible]
that as you know painters that
paints the walls of the [inaudible].
The main hall in New
York or I don't know
for instance regarding the
[inaudible] by chronological order
for instance we have
now a lot of key people.
That is working in the United
States in many important issues.
And one of them for instance is
[inaudible] Oncology Division
in the Harvard University, Medical
Director [inaudible] Hospital
in New York and President of the
American Association of [inaudible].
We have people [inaudible]
in Catalonia today
in the United States [inaudible].
Heart disease, etcetera, etcetera
and help people everywhere
and when we made the book we
find I have explained it to some
of you issues that we didn't know.
And one of them came
from the NASA you know,
in the United States we saw that
in Alabama, NASA has one museum
in which there is a permanent
[inaudible] is a permanent
explanation regarding [inaudible]
because he was really the inventor
of the jet engine in 1917.
1917 it's incredible and
that he test successfully.
And [inaudible] but finally
he was engaged in other issues
to create a new factory for
[inaudible] etcetera, etcetera
and then that is recognized is one
of the [inaudible] of
this kind of engines.
Well, in all fields there
are a lot of connections
with the United States and
we think that it is important
to increase the good
relationship between Catalonia
and the United States
in many issues.
Many people from United
States came now to Catalonia,
to visit Catalonia, we
are very proud of this
if you know we have one of the
most important cruises port
in Europe is Barcelona, then
we have a lot of visitors
from the United States
and the country.
We have a lot of Catalonians
that come here
to visit this fantastic nation.
Thank you very much for your
hospitality and of course we are
at your disposal for any
kind of this information.
Here we have two copies of the book
that if you feel this is the right
moment we can make the official
delivery of the offer of the book.
[ Applause ]
>> Carlos Olave: Thank you very
much and now Angela Kinney the chief
of the African-Latin American
and Western European Division
will accept the donation, Angela.
[ Applause ]
[ Background noise ]
>> Joan Amoros: More
than [inaudible].
>> Angela Kinney: I don't
know how I can handle this.
>> Joan Amoros: And here is this
folder as I explained to you
that is this full explanation
regarding the [inaudible].
Perhaps we can collect a photo.
>> Angela Kinney: Go
the side a little bit
on this side and [cross-talk].
>> Joan Amoros: I have to say
that the author of the cover
of the book is here with us, Mr.
[inaudible] is one of the authors
of the book as well,
specialist in all kinds of
[ Applause ]
>> Angela Kinney: Thank
you so much Mr. Amoros
for this wonderful publication.
Mr. Amoros actually took me
aside before this special program
to show me this publication both
the English and the Catalan version
and we're just extremely honored
that you thought of the Library
of Congress when you
were looking for a place
for this wonderful
publication to reside.
And my division, the African-Latin
American western European division
is actually in charge of
the cataloging as well
as the acquisition of materials
from the Iberian Peninsula.
So we are just thrilled to
receive this gift from you,
we know it's a labor of love of
many years and we're just very proud
to have it in the library's
collection.
So thank you so much for thinking
of us when making this donation.
As mentioned before Georgette Dorn,
my colleague, our colleague here
at the Library of Congress couldn't
be present today however Georgette
conveys here best wishes
to you and congratulations
on you getting this publication
in place and thanks you very much
for having donated this publication
to the Library of Congress.
We're just really, really excited
about having it in our collections,
getting it catalogued and having
it exposed to the general public
as a whole through
our online catalogue.
Georgette and I, our division, the
Hispanic division and my division
which we call ALAWE actually our
staff work together to ensure
that the Library's collections
in all formats are filled
with cultural heritage
materials from Spain
and other Hispanic countries.
In fact our divisions do a
lot of work in that respect
so that we ensure that the
richness and the history
of the Hispanic culture is
available to scholars world-wide.
Not just from them coming
to the Library of Congress
but actually seeing our collections
through our online catalogue.
So we're looking forward to having
these publications in English
and in Catalan in our catalogue.
The Library has been acquiring
materials in fact from Catalonia
since the 1950's through
various avenues.
We get publications
through purchase, exchange,
gifts and the deposit we
have a vendor [inaudible]
that actually resides in
and operates in Barcelona.
And the Library actually has
a treaty, a U.S. government
and Spanish treaty
and intergovernmental international
agreement that dates back to 1959.
That is with the National
Library of Spain.
And we acquire publications
from Spain through that treaty.
We also have exchange agreements
with various institutions in Spain
and so the library collects in
various formats and in various ways.
As I mentioned before through
various channels from Spain.
So today we're real excited to
have this publication as a gift
to the Library of Congress
and to be able
to accept this the Library's current
strategic plan highlights our
intention to fully connect with the
community outside of the library
and both in the U.S. as
well as in other countries.
And so acceptance of this wonderful
gift reinforces the Libraries
mission to enhance it's collections
with remarkable cultural heritage
publications like this one.
We're very gratified to you
for having donated this
publication to the library.
And so I would like to express again
my gratitude to you Mr. Amoros,
the President of the foundation
for choosing the library
as the stakeholder, the
placeholder for this publication.
We're just really, really
grateful to you for that,
thank you so much for that.
And thank you all for
attending this program.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.